hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think Cara i'm david griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and this is a review of Neil Blomkamp's
long-awaited Elysium yes long awaited
definitely excited for this graph
district nine which I thought was
amazing you know it's really curious to
see what the follow-up from Neil was
going to be yeah I love district nine as
well and so everyone was really looking
forward to this and I had heard before
we we had seen it you know some lukewarm
responses to it it's just like a lot
people expect it to be like the next
june nine or something and then i heard
some people saying like well it might
just be sure of action film i like you
know yeah and I have to you know what I
have to agree with with those people I
mean it was in I liked it it was good
you know um but it was no district nine
and I I didn't you know I didn't get
that same feeling of love for it I
really liked in there's some moments in
it that I really liked but it's
definitely I think story wise in with
the characters they didn't do as much um
compared to what do you do you think
right I definitely agree it wasn't the
same vibes ignite it wasn't quite as raw
you know definitely a little more money
bigger budget but I felt like he was
just kind of making like a science
fiction action movie in with a little
bit of heart to it you know more heart
than we've seen a lot of other movies
like this and I thought did a great job
without nailed and pulled it off so i
guess i was going here not really
expecting district nine and so it didn't
disappoint me at all yeah i was
expecting a little more from from maybe
the story in the character of like Matt
Damon's character max and stuff like
that so for me I thought it was you know
the action definitely delivered and
stuff like that but I feel like
story-wise it didn't you know kind of
have that same arc that district now I
wasn't expecting like another district
nine or anything like that what I'm
saying is in terms of the district nine
had this focus on this character and
what he was trying to do and and I don't
think they delve deep enough into into
Matt Damon's character even though Matt
Damon did a great job I think he did a
great job with with what he had and
stuff like that so what is movies sure
it's not like an hour and I say shorten
today's standards with ranger being two
and a half hours hours or the Rings like
three hours so this it was like an hour
and forty hour and 45 minutes tom so
they did have to do a lot quickly I felt
Damon was actually didn't mind the
courage problem with him I guess the
pounding characters Jodie Foster who was
fine I mean she wasn't barely in it yeah
I mean doing this proper not English but
I don't know what she was her accent
just trying to pull off very proper
sound I mean she was fine but I did I
wanted to know like with a co please
character with Kruger I want to know a
little bit more about them even though I
liked them on screen like Jodie Foster I
liked it but it's like I want to know
more about them I thought I guess I this
is one of the few movies I've seen this
summer we're actually wanted it to be
longer yeah not like we really two guns
a little while a little bit ago and I
wanted that movie like you know rear
back about 20 minutes this one I could
have had an extra 20 minutes in another
20 or 30 minutes to yawn it I felt like
they're what they were rushing stuff you
know we talked about man of steel with
with the flashbacks and how kind of rush
they were i think the the the same thing
happened with this movie just the
flashbacks you know go back and you know
try and tell the backstory of Max and
the girl that he loves but it's same you
seemed a little shorthand firm yeah I
think of credit i think for bomb camera
this is creation of worlds you know
district nine was a cool world going
into South Africa seeing how that was
going down now going into Los Angeles in
the year 2100 something I mean it was
just so cool to see the world he
envisioned I was really shocked to see
and don't think this is a spoiler just
how much of a Spanish influences I mean
no bum clamps is South African so to see
him kind of embrace this whole merger of
you know Mexico in Los Angeles and you
know Hispanic and you know you just
American culture mixing was really cool
I wasn't expecting to see that this
movie yeah definitely and the supporting
cast was pretty good i actually i think
my favorite thing about the movie was
kruger I like Kruger every time every
time I saw him on screen like yes you
know he's badass and just like the way
he put the gay I mean definitely there
wasn't like too much there wasn't really
any back history for a Kruger right but
I just like the way he portrayed him and
I thought he was a great villain yeah
like he was kind of off-the-wall crazy
you know but in almost a likeable way
right so yeah that was my favorite part
of it you know it's just seeing him
scene scene there was a lot of cool
visual effects I mean even small things
of the ships just flying down and
whatnot I actually thought we'd see more
of the kind of the Robo cops yeah Robo
police right we didn't see as much of
elysium's I thought we did we
been a lot more time in Los Angeles that
was fine i mean i think the movies about
matt damon's about his world it's not
about the the whole thing with the haves
and have-nots and it was more about the
have-nots and in Los Angeles so it was
good though but look great yeah yeah
they try to put a lot of different
themes in there not only with the heaven
have nasik universal health care
immigration I mean there are some strong
things here where I'm like okay we got
the mexican-american border is like this
really but I mean and maybe that's what
turn some crooks off and maybe thought
maybe he's preaching a little bit on
that but I thought it was fine because I
mean that's a relevant topic do well to
me it's not I wasn't turned off by any
type of preaching I was more turned off
that that because they try to do so many
things yeah that they weren't able to
concentrate you know Warren just like
one thing or another you know I think
that was my problem as opposed to I
don't I didn't feel like it was too
preachy now maybe a few times there's a
little over the top or whatever but I
just felt like they could have focused
more just like one aspect of it you know
everything I think this shows that you
know bomb campus he's a good director he
knows how to tell a story on to develop
a story's wasn't maybe a home run like
district knows i would say that like
he's not this isn't gonna be up for a
probably best picture we know i was but
this still is a good movie i can't wait
to see what he does next no he's working
on something right now so i can't wait
to see what he doesn't access yeah i
think more the problems leiden with more
the script than anything then the then
like the directing or anything like that
the world Burt building is great and you
know a lot of cool things that happen
but definitely for me was it was a bit
kind of a little over the overall place
and stuff like that so what are your
overall thoughts and grades I really
enjoyed this I'm definitely give it a B+
again didn't like didn't give the same
in fact me for district nine it wasn't
quite as invented but I mean it still
was it shows it like i said earlier bomb
camp is he's a good director and he's
passionate about size money wants to
make i mean how many directors there are
out there right now they're making good
sci-fi movies consistently so i'm happy
that he's doing this so i definitely get
a b-plus okay i'm gonna give it a be i
just i liked it i definitely did it
definitely isn't on that same level is
just not i think the story and strip
could have been like tightened its weird
it could have been tightened and then
also at the same time expanded right you
know it's one of those things
where it sounds weird but it's like yeah
they could have just focused a little
more but then also gone on depth more
with with the characters and maybe some
of the storylines and whatnot so I think
you know I i think it's worth watching
yeah you know it's a lot of cool action
visual fact support Blomkamp's we get
more movies and we do more sci-fi oh
yeah you know and I think like I think
maybe like even the big-budget kind of
hurt him in a way because like I think
with all that money and stuff like you
know with all that money you kind of
have to deliver a certain type of movie
I am the studio's can expect exactly
certain things I'm glad they kept it at
our though yes I am dedicated are they
could have gone pg-13 when I'm glad they
kept at it are yeah so I think almost in
that sense he kind of got hurt by but
you know not it's still still a good
movie ever i still recommend seeing it
so alright guys so let us know what you
think you can post your comments below
on our website or on this youtube video
on our youtube channel make sure you
subscribe to our youtube channel it's a
think hero pro it goes by us on twitter
i'm at griffin de and i'm on i'm at
think Kira and also we have a Facebook
page that's a facebook.com slash thank
your fans
you